he assaulted the customer grab the cash
and ran out so he's how say when
height-wise I'm gonna start up here just
tell me what I'll start in the bottom
whatever 510 is he was 510 ethnically I
mean did what I was he was he like us or
a woman
female know like pretend forever what's
the African African oh he was American
and he was like you you look just like
you Jewish just like give me some odd
conferred June Hannah I'm pretty docile
now there's a lot of ways I can do this
for you one of them is I could stab him
in the nut that's something I did once
and I'm very comfortable doing it again
what or not why forget about it
who would want this can't you just shoot
him yeah because being shot is very
painful
ha man I can't be late on the first day
I made it my first day of class and this
school is over son
you missed it great I live my life by
numbers you see this watch it tells me
how many calories I burn at any time
question how many calories do you think
I burned walking from there to there you
female closest to me oh uh three three
try 0.8 numbnuts
any questions sax bottom said oh my god
that is not my name Tiger to me yeah no
said second a box
no synced Amaya mission accomplished
okay private another you think of your
superiors what emotions do you feel well
I have a double uterus you know that Amy
knows that and you can't we we have how
many kids are you well we have we have
flip for little before it's for living
yeah and then she has two more sorry
sorry oh yeah that sounds fantastic
what was that that wasn't anything like
joy ah because I'm not joy yeah no
kidding
whoa know something I am high [__] right
now dude I just I just looked like three
toads I've been up for like 27 sons up
and sons downs okay I just want to get a
meal I am a pig things for a game huh
well [__] you all right be careful I'm a
theme those your parents yeah you want a
picture everyone please shut up the
judges are coming in we only have one
chance at this and go for leaf will you
crime when your hair's blew up no
rigging in this no why Sean right
of course we're getting in the [__]
water food then waiting for you
wait where's the other guy one two three
four Oh hurry
all of you and especially a baby on the
ground with you how long have you been
waiting today Monday been 65 million
years all right Rico listen um there's
an ancient Italian Maxim that roughly
translates to he who is resistant to
change is destined to perish so why
don't you try open up that bond years
you know it's like look at Kennedy
reassure me so he's a jerk noogie
villager I like him he's just I wouldn't
necessarily like curl up with him and
watch Breaking Bad
don't say anything my Breaking Bad and
seen season five years the whole thing
done you done we're not talking about it
okay